it is the last day of CES 2016 and we're
talking about some of the big overall
trends we've noticed that the show this
year one thing that really stood out so
far is that there's a lot of old stuff
by that we mean a lot of retro and
italjet we've seen turntables they've
been some of the most popular items here
as well as cameras that don't actually
do anything digital they print this
that's really fun adds kind of a little
bit of pitch to the show and they've
been some of the most popular products
on the other hand we're seeing things
that are actually old as in launched six
months ago or a year ago maybe they were
even here at the last CES some of them
have little updates here and there a new
button the new feature but overall these
are not definitely specifically new
products last year a huge huge thing
here were wearables a 3d printing and
drones two of those have kind of fallen
into the shadow a little bit wearables
and 3d printing they're definitely here
everybody has an activity tracker a
SmartWatch and every corner has a 3d
printer but they haven't been the big
stars of the show their people don't
come out and talk about them quite as
much as they did in the last couple
years that said drones are still huge if
not even bigger than they've been in
years past and we're seeing more
specific drones not just a bunch of
drones doing the same thing it's got one
set can fit a person in them or ones
that are uncrackable so they're getting
more specific and hitting a niche market
the biggest star here this year is the
Internet of Things the really cool thing
this year is that the technology that is
enabling the Internet of Things and
Smart Homes has gotten really really
good this is definitely like a new point
of capability for the Internet of Things
so we're seeing a lot of experimentation
since the background technology is so
sophisticated now and it makes it really
excited for what we're going to be able
to see maybe next year at CES